Present only nature.
He came to that conclusion.
It was many people have come to that conclusion,
but I think the two who've outlined it most spectacularly,
we're Nietzsche and Dostoevsky had niche is an unbelievably influential
philosopher.
You know,
I don't think there was anyone that was more influential
during the entire course of the 20th century accepting a very,
very tiny handful of other people accepting the scientists.
We won't bother with their,
where their discussion,
you could put marks in that category,
you could put Freud in that category partly,
but after that the list starts to get a lot thinner,
you know?
So maybe there's 10 people up and out level and Dostoyevsky of course,
I think,
I mean,
if,
if you ever,
if anybody ever prepares a list of the top 10 greatest literary figures in the
world,
he would be in the top 10 list.
You know,
I think he's perhaps second to Shakespeare and may be above Shakespeare in my
estimation.
So these aren't trivial people were talking about and they weren't dealing with
trivial issues.
Well.
So then the question might be,
what's at the bottom of the idea of a transcendent value?
And I want to want it to approach that
staying out of the metaphysical domain as much as possible because you can claim
anything you want from a metaphysical perspective and that's a big problem.
And so people will say,
well,
why come up with a hypothesis of God?
For example,
God could be anything.
There's a satire,
uh,
the flying Spaghetti Monster,
right,
is classic satirical representation of a day at that the atheist types used to
buttress their arguments and fair enough,
you know,
as a satirical idea,
it's pretty damn funny,
but there's things about this that aren't the least bit of music.
And the thing that's not amusing as well.
What,
if anything,
is our culture predicated on,
okay,
so what happened?
Well,
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky put this forth,
this set of propositions and out of Dostoyevsky's line of thinking to some
degree grew soldier,
netsuite,
and so as units and documented the absolute horrors of equity predicated Soviet
society,
you know,
and we don't teach,
we don't learn about that,
right?
This,
I don't understand is that what happened in the 20th century on the radical left
end of the spectrum is not well documented.
Students don't learn about it.
Why the hell is that?
We learned about World War II,
we learned about what happened in the Holocaust and fair enough,
we absolutely should,
but nobody knows.
It's a mystery to everyone when,
when I talk about what happened in the Soviet Union and that's absolutely
appalling and that's to say nothing about what happened in China,
which was equally horrible.
Yeah,
the system didn't work.
It was predicated on the wrong values.
Unless you think that that sort of thing means work,
you know,
cause you,
you have to define that as well.
But it collapsed under its own weight after it killed tens of millions of
people.
That doesn't really instill Ritz.
Not like Russia has recovered.
It doesn't seem to me like that's a very good definition of worked.
Now whatever we're doing in the West seems to work for all of its flaws.
And the question is,
are we just deceiving ourselves?
Is it just arbitrary power,
politics and opinion,
or is there something at the bottom of it?
Yeah,
so when Soulja knits and wrote the Gulag archipelago,
he believed that the Russians would have to return to Orthodox Christianity to
find their pathway forward.
And that's of course has made him into a reactionary in the eyes of many of his
critics.
But that is perhaps what is happening in Russia.
Although it's very difficult to tell because Putin also seems to be using his
affiliation with the Orthodox Christian Church as as it means to consolidate
power.
So the situation in Russia is unclear,
but a religious revival,
if that's happening in Russia,
and perhaps it isn't,
but if it is happening,
is something that unfolds over decades and even centuries.
So it's not an easy thing to evaluate when it first starts to happen.
Okay.
But soldier knits and drew the same conclusions that Dostoyevsky did.
Fundamentally.
I'm not,
not in exactly the same way,
but very,
very close.
He,
he believed as far as I could tell that unless people were willing to adhere to
some sort of transcendent value,
that they had no protection against pathological ideologies and no protection
against the murderous impulses that came along with them.
And I found his work in unbelievably,
I found his right.
Incredible,
powerful,
incredible.
I don't know how you can read that book and not draw that kind of conclusion.
I think people who criticize soldier nets and have never read the damn book
because that book is like,
it's like going into the ring with Mohammed Ali and being pummeled to death for
half an hour.
You know,
you don't recover from it that easily.
So
then young branched off of nature.
Okay.
And so niche,
his idea was that people would have to create their own values,
roughly speaking.
And I think that's where niches is.
We,
uh,
is his weakest because it isn't obvious to me that people can create their own
values.
And I think he fell into,
I don't want to be a casual critic of nature because that's always dangerous
given that he probably had an Iq of 260,
you know,
I mean,
he was way the hell out there in the stratosphere.
And just when you think you've understood what he was talking about,
you can be bloody well sure that you didn't.
But it does seem to me,
and he was running out of time,
he died young,
you know,
when he was trying to solve this problem in a rush,
I would say.
And he hypothesized that people would have to become superman over men,
roughly speaking in order to deal with the death of God.
And that idea sort of branched off into Nazi propaganda because that's in some
sense with the Nazis were trying to do with their promotion of the,
of the perfect area.
You know,
now it's a mist.
It's a misappropriation of nature in my estimation.
And it was partly because his sister who was a perverse creature,
um,
uh,
what would you say?
Doctored his work in such a way so that it was more easily appropriated by the
Nazis.
But there is some danger in what he said too.
Because you know the,
the question is,
well,
if you're going to transform yourself into the,
into the giver of values,
what stops you from inflating yourself into something like a demigod and just
pronouncing what the values are going to be.
So that's a problem.
You know,
you're going to replace tradition with yourself.
Well,
there's dangers in that because there's nothing to keep you humble.
That's,
that's the most appropriate objection.
There's nothing to keep you humble.
And those things can spiral out of control very rapidly.
And they did say in the case of Hitler,
I mean it's easy to blame what happened in Germany on Hitler,
but that's a,
that's a big mistake because it was a dialogue between Hitler and the German
people,
right?
Hitler didn't create himself.
It was cocreation.
He said things people listened and told him back what to say.
And then he said them and they listened and they told him back what to say.
And it looped until he was the mouthpiece of their darkest desires.
Now that's a good,
that's a game he was willing to play.
But you can't think about that as it isn't like Hitler created Nazi Germany,
Hitler and the Germans cocreated Nazi Germany now.
And a leader gives our articulation to the imagination of the population.
That's what a leader does.
And you know,
you could say that,
well,
Hitler may be Hitler filtered what the Germans were telling him through a
particular lens because he had no shortage of resentment and desire for revenge
in his own heart.
You know,
um,
it's not like his life was his spectacular success be before he became a
political activist.
And he was brutalized very badly in world war one.
And he didn't get to pursue his primary dream,
which was to be an art student in Vienna.
And he had applied three times and got rejected all three times.
And so he was bitter about that.
He was basically living on the streets after World War One.
It wasn't the world's happiest person,
and I'm sure he carried a fair bit of resentment in his heart when he was in the
trenches in world war war one at,
at in one experience that he had,
all of his friends were killed by a mortar when he had wandered off to go do
something else.
So,
you know,
it's hard to even imagine what something like that would do to you,
but I can tell you when you're the only survivor out of 20 people,
that's also going to give you an enhanced sense of your own specialists.
Because the alternative is just to think about how God damn arbitrary the
universe really is.